ela só usa mais um vídeo e hoje eu vou
estar maneira que tenha bastante tempo
que é uma crosta bull e eu não vou
pintar como fiz neste modelo aqui porque
se for pintar cá dentro os gases que
conca dentro também isso acaba por
afetar a missão é tão mais para frente
isso pensávamos musicais e que vai ter
lá vencedores
os vencedores vão mandar os gases para
fora e sim o pintado estar mudou
jesuítas que o time quem não foram
pintadas que você consegue ver algumas
aqui no planeta
ae agora começar a contar como arma é
então bora lá
[Música]
ainda nesse primeiro teste para ver
samira conti na barriga você consegue
consultar aqui funciona e de que maneira
a única coisa que você tem que fazer e
manter aquela coisa laranja que o pino
pequenino no meio daqueles do exposto e
200 anos 50 e 60 a gente parar em álbuns
mais longe é só você se inclinarem arma
para cima uma coisa muito importante é
que quando vocês forem para disparar não
podem tirar mas que encontra em nossa
direção
fiquem estáveis e depois é só pegar no
pt estuda o teste para ganharmos
modificadas e vocês vão ver que eu vou
falhar algumas vezes isso aconteceu
porque fica um pouco mais difícil manter
a arma estava
[Música]
e vai investir aqui era simular uma
situação em que o álbum está em
movimento e conseguir votar todas as
balas menos uma mas não vou mostrar o
texto do futuro que eu estou a ficar
tonto do olhar para aquela standard um
lado a outro e acabei por vocês também
fiquem que eu gosto e não gosto de estar
lá em termos de design ela está muito
bonita mesmo porém não gosto do
carregador aqui atrás parece que não
combina com o resto da arma
gostaria que tivesse um carteiro dos
cinco ou seis balas algo sim do tipo é
mais para frente está a pensar comprar
mancini porém usará que os cabelos que
no saque nem estarão e talvez aí
problema
depois é muito então vocês querem
estavam corretamente porque não fizerem
depois acabam por estragar as balas aqui
para entender tanto tempo você tem essa
partida tem que puxar tudo para trás
depois tudo para frente à cae porque
essa partida ficará mais vocês correm o
risco de entrar várias balas e portando
ficou modificados ficam os empregados
até então muito importante jato trás
depois tudo para frente mas ficarem
travados nos preocupa e é bastante fácil
tirar vez que fizeram estas aberturas
aqui que vocês tão pessoal abrir e tirar
a bola dele ficava depois em termos de
mira é muito boa mesmo que vocês
conseguiram ver isso nos testes basta
olhar para que me alinhar esta parte com
esta parte é tão facilmente
depois né alto na hora de acertar é
muito bom porque tem essa parte da reta
e vocês conseguem estar contra o ombro e
assim é muito fácil de acertar por em
primeiro quando você encosta está contra
o ombro corre o risco de clicar nesse
botão que ia jogar o carregador para o
chão quer então sem nenhum cuidado
conectarem se contra o muro
espero que eu possa fazer aqui no canal
ou algum mar você gostaria que o
processo aqui pro canal para testar
deixe nos comentários
até a próxima